major left-leaning cities push a bevy of
insanely backwards policies the White
House prepares for the g7 and Bernie
Sanders wants to spend all of your money
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show we have a lot to get to today the
late-breaking news right before the show
is the passing of David Koch he's the
conservative billionaire obviously he's
become this Bugaboo to the left but
that's because the left doesn't
understand who David Koch was and if you
watched the response on Twitter Twitter
is just the worst place on earth it is
just a garbage heap of humanity it's
it's horrible horrible horrible if you
read the tweets you're looking at
reporters like Matthew Chapman from Raw
Story saying the definitive top 10 list
of modern people who have done the most
damage to America Rupert Murdoch Mitch
McConnell Charles Koch David Koch and
then you get the tweet of God which is
this popular stupid parody account 6
million followers saying
r.i.p David Koch that's a request to
Satan rip him and Michael Ian Black
tweeted out in lieu of flowers the
family of David Koch requests that
mourners simply purchase a Republican
politician I mean this is just
disgusting it's disgusting I mean
Twitter is an awful awful place David
Roth who is a reporter supposedly at
Deadspin which is ridiculous website
owned by Ted Cruz he tweeted out David
Koch had a dream which was to make
things easier for himself and a few
friends while also making things
significantly worse for everyone else on
the planet he is gone but now that work
falls to all of us today whenever you
get a chance harm someone vulnerable I
mean this is the the way that the left
treats the death of a man who gave
hundreds of millions of dollars in
charity to many of the institution's
they like and they don't know anything
about David Koch all they know is that
he's a Bugaboo all they know is that
David Koch is mean because he gave a lot
of money to Republican politicians
doesn't matter that he didn't support
Trump in 2016 all that matters is that
David Koch was a Republican and all
Republicans are bad and then you wonder
how you got Trump guys it's because it
doesn't matter what the belief system is
of anyone with an R next to their name
so long as there's an R next to their
name they are the face and root of all
evil we saw this when John McCain died
too there are people on the Left talking
about the evils of John McCain who is a
very mod
Republican David Koch passes away at the
age of 79 and it no longer matters that
David Koch ends it that he had given an
enormous amount of money to all sorts of
various non partisan enterprises who's a
major benefactor of the Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center at Dan's
focused theater at Lincoln Center bears
his name he gave a hundred million
dollars to the Lincoln Center last year
Koch Industries said that cokes
donations and pledges to philanthropic
organizations had topped 1.3 billion
dollars it has not money that he was
sucking out of somebody else's pocket
via the courtesy of government that was
money that he was spending out of his
own pocket on charitable causes but he's
very very bad now you would think from
all of this that David Koch was some
rabid right-wing or david koch was a
libertarian guys David Koch was an early
supporter of same-sex marriage David
Koch to the end of his life was not
pro-life that does not matter so long as
David Koch gave money to Republican
causes and free-market causes he was
evil and understand that this is how a
lot of the Democratic Left feels about
anybody who spends any money in pursuit
of politics who spends any time pushing
right-wing meaning libertarian causes
anybody who pushes for limited
government and free markets is a bad guy
I mean this is how it is headlined at
CNN David Koch billionaire businessman
an influential GOP donor dies and the
entire beginning of the article doesn't
really talk about his company which is
responsible for the employment of a full
hundred and twenty thousand people in
the United States Bernie Sanders is good
he's never employed a human being that
he has paid for himself not one it's all
been paid for by taxpayer dollars but
he's good the essence of good on the far
left is that if you work at the expense
of taxpayer dollars and you never create
anything you are good if you are a David
Koch and you're responsible for the
creation from the huge company and you
hire 120,000 people and you give 1.3
billion dollars in charity including an
enormous amounts of charity to
nonpartisan excellent causes like the
arts and fighting cancer then you are
evil because you also gave money to
Republican causes I honestly do not know
how we can continue to have a republic
when people like David Koch are
demonized by the left
now a lot of them are said well you know
he was in the gas industry well he was
in the gas industry yeah you know what
else a lot of people are in the gas
industry you want all of them out of
work and David Koch again was an
important voice in the political debate
but he was not the rabid right-wing
crazy that so many on the Left paint him
to be
here's CNN reporting Koch retired from
his company and the Koch political
operations in 2018 citing health reasons
sources close to the family told CNN he
had been in declining health in recent
weeks the Koch brothers were best known
and vilified by Democrats for their role
in politics and they used their vast
wealth to build a sprawling array of
think tanks foundations and political
groups to spread their small government
free-market message so evil small
government free market messaging brutal
brutal in some elections the Koch
Network rivaled the spending and scope
of the National Republican Party
analysts view their activism as helping
to have fueled the Tea Party movement
who a movement that called for a smaller
government
oh so terrible Koch was most active in
Americans for Prosperity the grassroots
arm of the Koch sprawling Network which
built a coalition of more than 3 million
activists to push the agenda of the
cokes and the roughly 700 like-minded
donors to help fund their public policy
work I love it whenever people on the
Left suggest that a campaign donation is
said that they will push the agenda of
the person donating as the politics is a
simple art of bribery
okay well then unions who donate to
politicians are bribing the politicians
Tom Styer is bribing politicians George
Soros
yes George Soros is bribing politicians
this is your logic if your logic is that
if you give them money to a politician
who supports the agenda that you also
support that you are therefore bribing
the politician then all campaign
donations are bribery and that would
include Democratic billionaires in the
era of President Donald Trump the
network has undergone a significant
shift in focus upping its commitment to
work across party lines on top
priorities like free trade and creating
a path to permanent legal status for
undocumented immigrants again they're a
libertarian they're very very soft on
illegal immigration in June Americans
for Prosperity announced four new
political action committees and said it
would wade into primaries to help
incumbent politicians including
Democrats who side with Koch on trade
immigration and other issues obviously
David Koch was supremely evil according
to the
because he was rich and because they
gave lots of money and because they were
Republicans the treatment of the Koch
brothers was shoddy during their
lifetime and it's shoddy after his death
so that is not a major shock okay
meanwhile in other news America's major
cities governed by the Democratic Left
happen to suck I mean like they they
they are just the living conditions are
getting worse and worse in America's
major cities and that is because of
stupid policies being pursued out of
feeling but not out of actual sympathy
for taxpayers or for rule of law we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about how you're going to
lose weight and get in shape now I'm
somebody who works out nearly everyday I
try to watch my diet still I was having
a tough time taking off those final five
pounds and then I started using Newman
the reason that Newman works is because
Newman isn't just about okay here's what
you should eat and now usually it's
about changing a way of life it's a
psychological approach to weight loss
and getting in shape and you can set
your specific goals that you want to
achieve with new not just losing weight
now you can set goals of how much weight
you want to lose but also how much
exercise you want to do yet they set up
system so that you can talk with other
people who are pursuing the same goals
that you are numa's a habit changing
solution that really is the key they
want to change your habits it helps
users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses based in psychology
Noom teaches you why you do the things
you do and arms you with the tools to
break the bad habits and replace them
with better ones
NUMA since a diet it's a healthy easy to
stick to way of life you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon and oom comm slash appear
oh that's Noom comm slash Shapiro to
start your trial today
NUMA comm slash appear what is the last
weight loss program you'll need because
then it ain't weight loss and it's just
maintaining your habits Noom comm slash
apparel go check them out right now
really is fantastic
alrighty so as I say America's major
cities governed almost solely by
Democrats are doing an amazing job of
making what used to be nice cities into
worse places so this week Texas has
joined the national battle over of the
urban homeless crisis the City of Austin
has now made it legal to sleep on the
street
I can't imagine they're gonna have an
increased homeless problem in the city
of
austan like we have here in the city of
Los Angeles according to the Washington
Post
Christopher Paula hasn't felt a police
officer tapping at his foot in more than
a month the tap tap tap that usually
meant he was about to get another
citation that he was never going to pay
living on the streets for five years
after he lost his graphic design job
Paul has been having undisturbed nights
since the City Council and mayor eased
restrictions on public camping this
summer a move that liberal lawmakers
billed as a humane and pragmatic reform
of the criminal justice system but the
change has drawn the ire of Republicans
and local business owners who decry it
as a threat to public safety and the
local economy exposing a partisan clash
over how to manage poverty and
affordable housing in America cities yes
because it turns out that your feelings
of sympathy for the homeless are in
direct contravention of public order and
rule of law allowing people to sleep in
public on streets outside businesses
drives down the ability of businesses to
do their job which drives down the
taxpayer dollars that you need to fund
the city it makes the cities dirtier it
makes the cities more difficult to
manage in terms of both crime and in
terms of disease we have seen it here in
Los Angeles in Seattle in San Francisco
Austin has their public camping ban
relaxed according to Christopher Paul
this homeless person who again has been
homeless for five years since losing his
graphic design job he couldn't find any
other job he was working in graphic
design there are no jobs anywhere in the
country for a guy who was doing graphic
design for five years somehow I find
this a little bit hard to believe we
have a three point seven percent
unemployment rate in this country there
there is nothing law-abiding about
loitering and trespassing on public
property nothing this is not about lack
of sympathy for somebody who is homeless
particularly in the short term but when
you decide to make the decision to live
on the street for five years when there
are homeless shelters available in a
bevy of cities when you are in fact
living on the street with all of your
crap presumably you are defecating in
public because where else would you do
it my sympathy is with the taxpayers my
sympathy is with the businesses my
sympathy is with the law abiding in that
community
Paul says people can sleep better in the
open they're a lot safer than somewhere
hiding in a back alley he estimates that
he has received twenty citations for
illegal camping before the rule went
into effect on July 1st but as Paul 50
sprawled out shirtless on the sidewalk
on 100 degree day shop owner Craig
Staley stood
you feet away on Congress Avenue
reconsidering his party affiliation
Staley said I got two emails last month
from customers who said I can't go to
your store anymore because it smells
like urine I'm a Democrat at heart I've
been in Austin Texas for over 30 years
but I'm telling you I'm feeling a lot
more red these days when it comes to my
business ya know bleep it turns out know
everybody is sympathetic to the homeless
until they start peeing on your front
doorstep
there is nothing law-abiding or decent
for the city or by the way decent for
people who a large a large plurality or
majority of people who are homeless
suffer from severe mental illness or
drug addiction
it is not sympathetic to leave someone
severely schizophrenic on the street
talking to themselves living in their
own filth I don't know how that is
deemed to be sympathetic with an
estimated 2200 homeless adults sleeping
on sidewalks and in makeshift tent
cities Austin has become the latest
flashpoint in the national debate over
whether homeless residents have a
constitutional right to sleep on public
streets particularly in cities grappling
with overcrowded shelters
yes I'm sure this is what the founders
meant they meant that you have the
freedom to sleep right in front of
somebody else's business and pee on
their doorstep I am sure that that is
exactly what the founders meant
constitutional right to sleep in public
sure the city of Boise Idaho plans to
appeal a ruling from the US Court of
Appeals for the Ninth Circuit which
applies in nine Western states the
ruling determined that criminalizing
public sleeping is unconstitutional when
there is inadequate shelter space what
absolute crap unconstitutional to
criminalize public sleeping really so if
there are insufficient public restrooms
let's say the restroom is full in one
day can I just crap in the open because
apparently according to the same logic I
should be able to after all the toilet
is occupied and I got to go meanwhile my
favorite thing about left-leaning media
coverage is whenever Democrats push a
really garbage policy the story is
Republicans pouncing so here it is
according to the Washington Post
meanwhile Republicans have made the
nation's growing homeless population a
political weapon characterizing it as a
failure of liberal policies yet you know
why cuz it is a failure of liberal
policies I've vanilla in LA my entire
life the city was not always like this
every single bench in the city of Los
Angeles is now occupied by a homeless
person that is a public safety threat a
lot of these people have criminal
backgrounds not
all of them many of them many of them
are schizophrenic
many of them have severe mental illness
a huge number of them are drug addict
you think that's safe for a city you
think that is that is great for the
public life of a city it is not
sympathetic to the homeless it is not
sympathetic to the people who have to
live in the community around the
homeless this is it's really bad policy
and again it is sympathy for one
particular group of people overtaking a
policy that actually makes a city better
for everyone everybody was all over Rudy
Giuliani in the 90s and early 2000s when
he was cleaning up the homeless problem
in New York except that he helped turn
New York and the center of New York
particularly from one of the worst
seediest places in America it's one of
the best president Trump said at a
Cincinnati rally this month look at LA
with the tents and the horrible horrible
conditions look at San Francisco look at
some of her other cities California
governor Gavin Newsom said that
Democratic policies have fueled the
economic resurgence of US cities that it
has caused a short-term increase in
homelessness well wait so he's gonna
have to explain according to the
Democrats the reason there's a
homelessness crisis is because people
are too poor to afford housing and it
apparently according to Gavin Newsom it
is a burgeoning booming economy in
democratic areas that is causing the
homeless problem so which is it
California is home to nearly half of the
nation's homeless people who do not yell
who do not use shelters which suggests a
lot of people are coming from other
states and camping out in LA cities what
and in California cities why because the
weather is good and because they know
they're not going to be moved and
because the ACLU has prevented the
police from a moving bags of crap on LA
sidewalks in LA you're apparently
allowed to sleep in your car as long as
possible
Newsom said we don't need the
president's megaphone to tell us that we
have challenges adding the California is
spending 1.7 billion dollars to address
housing affordability again this is the
same state that is about to implement a
totalitarian rent control statute that
basically makes it impossible for
developers to create new units in Austin
governor Greg Abbott has threatened to
push the GOP dominated Texas Legislature
to pass a law overriding Austin's public
camping action which is what should
happen mat makovica chairman of the
county party in travis county
he says they thought it would be
compassionate and not a big deal but it
has been an absolute disaster for the
city this is our best exam
of overreach so we've been strategically
focusing on this issue but the Austin
mayor Democrat he says when you move
these people they don't disappear they
just go somewhere else yes that's true
they go not outside businesses and they
don't drive down the tax base and
provide a public safety hazard in
different areas of the city now
obviously that doesn't mean you should
shuttle them into low-income areas which
is the other solution you've seen from
Democrats in these cities he says the
real answer is not just moving people
from theirs who over and back again
the real answer is giving them the
services they need oh really because as
it turns out the City of Seattle has
what they literally call the drunk dorms
where they do not have restrictions on
people getting drunk or using drugs in
these affordable housing units and these
places have turned into festering
centers for crime and drug use which is
not a particularly ously the city
prohibited sitting or lying down on
public sidewalks are sleeping outdoors
in downtown Austin between 2014 and 2016
Austin police issued 18,000 citations
for rule violations but those cited
didn't show up for court 90% of the time
yes but the point is that you don't want
people feeling the ability to settle
down on the sidewalk as a permanent
housing solution as we'll see the city
of Los Angeles has been backing off of
its own stupid policies on this sort of
stuff because even Democrats are
realizing that this is bad policy after
a while facts get in the way of feelings
as I'm fond of saying it we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the necessity of
putting together a trust or will the
fact is there are a lot of politicians
who basically want to steal your money
after you die the estate tax is a way of
stealing your money yes you already pay
taxes on all the money in your estate
and you want to pass it on to your
relatives
well now the government would like to
steal more and more and more of that
which is why you really need to set up a
living will you need to set up a trust
and right now is actually the perfect
time to do it during national make well
month at LegalZoom for more than 18
years LegalZoom has developed a
straightforward way for you to protect
what you care about most your family and
the assets that would go to them this
all starts with a last will or a living
trust estate plan if that sounds
confusing don't worry LegalZoom can help
you out they have a ton of online
resources for you to figure out what's
right for you if that's not enough their
network of independent attorneys can
provide advice if you need more
direction LegalZoom is not a law firm so
you won't be billed by the hour it's
easier to fit what you need to get done
into your busy schedule joint over
million people who have counted on
LegalZoom for a will or living trust
before another summer passes by again
trust well these are really important
documents and and get them done pretty
easily over at legalzoom.com its
national make will month at
legalzoom.com for special savings be
sure to enter promo code been in the
referral box to check out that his code
been for special savings only at
legalzoom.com
where life meets legal go check them out
right now so as i say la was a leader in
the let's just let the homeless take
over the city movement and now they're
backing off of it shock because it turns
out taxpayers not particularly happy
when you walk outside your front door
and there's some dude shooting heroin
into his foot LA's city council
homelessness and poverty committee on
wednesday according to la Escom
recommended repealing a controversial
ordinance prohibiting homeless people
from sitting or sleeping on sidewalks
the committee wants city council to
replace the law with one that is more
narrowly tailored and compliant with a
recent federal court decision the
ordinance Municipal Code section 41 18
known and homeless advocacy circles as
the sit-lie law makes it a criminal
offence to sit light or sleep on a
public sidewalk anywhere in the city the
law is the subject of a major lawsuit
Jones versus LA which was settled in
2007 right now the city can only enforce
the law under limited circumstances the
proposed replacement law lays out a
lengthy list of circumstances and
conditions under which occupying a
sidewalk would be banned these include
within 500 feet of parks and schools and
within ten feet of a driveway or
building entrance yes this will
certainly solve the problems will
shuttle people over five feet and
that'll definitely fix it
committee members and city Attorneys
offices are recommending the change in
order to align LA's Municipal Code with
the 2018 federal court ruling that
limits how cities can enforce anti
camping and anti loitering laws in that
case the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
struck down a Boise law that outlawed
sleeping in any public space in that
city the judge in that case because the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals is an
awful terrible horrible legal
institution wrote as long as there is no
option of sleeping indoors the
government cannot criminalize indigent
homeless people for sleeping outdoors on
public property on the false premise
they had a choice in the matter
well yes as long as there is freedom to
travel in the United States you do have
a choice as to where you choose to live
the city in that case had no shelter
beds it is not the city's duty it really
is not it is not the city's duty to
provide a bed for everybody in the city
that is
not the way the Constitution of the
United States works I mean really so now
that now the idea is that if you if the
city doesn't pay for your car then you
have a ride too right the bus for free
you have a right to ride the bus for
free that's that's how this works now if
the city doesn't pay for something that
you want then you get to just take
advantage of city services and violate
the law in doing so the LA the LA
council law that is currently on the
books is virtually identical to the
Boise law but it has not been enforced
there are more than 27,000 people
experiencing unsheltered homelessness in
the city of LA at any given time there
about 80-100 shelter beds more than half
of those beds are reserved for families
with children thousands of people are
living on the sidewalk so here is the
list of proposed restrictions within 10
feet of a driveway or building entrance
but other than that I guess you're fine
so if you just sleep within eleven feet
you're fine within 500 feet of a park
school or daycare center because that'll
certainly solve the problem being 500
feet away having a homeless encampment
500 feet away from the entrance of a
kindergarten is fantastic on bike paths
ten tunnels bridged pedestrians Subway's
that is on city designated school routes
on public land with posted no
trespassing signs and public crowded
sidewalk areas the proposed law would
make it illegal to follow or speak to a
person in a manner that could cause them
to fear for their safety or property or
in to intimidate a person into giving
money or cause them to respond
immediately with a violent reaction
because of the inherent nature of the
perceived harm naturally homeless
advocates are calling this inhumane hey
our cities are turning into trash heaps
and this is Democratic policy all the
way through how stupid by the way is the
Democratic policy getting San Francisco
is introducing a new law you ready for
this there now they want to change the
law so that the law does not contain the
words offender or addict and they also
want to change the phrase convicted
felon to justice involved person justice
involved person so you get out of jail
after 11 years for a second-degree
murder or something you are now a
justice involve person just like a
lawyer is a justice involved person
you're a justice involved person the
Board of Supervisors adopted the changes
last month even as the city
from one of the highest crime rates in
the country and staggering inequality
exemplified by pervasive homelessness
alongside Silicon Valley wealth the
local officials say the new language
will help change people's views about
those who commit crime yeah I'm sure
that's right I'm sure now now that
you're now that you said it that rapist
who is a justice-involved person I think
of him not anymore as a convicted rapist
no I think of him as just a person who
is unfortunately and against his will
involved in the criminal justice system
it's unreal it's unreal
these policies don't work they're
specifically designed at covering over
the failure of democratic policies and I
love how the media cover it this stuff
in the New York Times has a story today
about education in the city of New York
City school test scores inch up but less
than half of students pass oopsie-doodle
turns out that that education in the
city of New York where they spend
enormous resources only 46 percent of
the city's 3rd through 8th graders
passed the state math exam a three
percentage point increase from last year
only 47 percent of students passed the
English exam
everything is going great in democratic
government cities it's all wonderful you
can't focus on any of the underlying
problems you can't focus on the mental
health problem you can't focus on the
drug addiction problem when it comes to
homelessness you can't focus on the
problem of single-parent families who
have to split their attention between
work and making sure their kid has help
with their homework you can't focus on
any of the underlying problems instead
we just say the criminals are
justice-involved persons we say that
homeless people are not homeless they're
just unsheltered and we suggest that
educational failures are the result of
not spending enough money on education
how wonderful how wonderful and this is
how you get to by the way a Democratic
Party that has now fully embraced the
idea that the only measure of sympathy
is how much money you spend on crap
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about dressing well so
let's say that you don't want to look
like a schlub anymore you're sick of
going down to the local department store
and picking a suit off the rack and it
hangs off of you like a pair of drapes
and now instead you should head on over
to Indo Chino great suits are worth it
you're gonna wear it a lot and if it's
tailored to you you look like a million
bucks this is where Indo Chino comes in
Indo Chino makes suits and shirts to
your exact measurements your Indo Chino
suit is made for you they have attention
to detail that beats any department
store if you're in the middle of
planning a
they've tons of options for people
looking to outfit their wedding party so
here's how it works you can visit one of
their showrooms and no chino has over 40
showrooms in north america a stylist
will take your measurements personally
or you can measure at home and shop
online at endo chino comm so I actually
went to one of their showrooms it really
is fun you feel like you're on Savile
Row it's it's pretty awesome and if you
do it online it's the same sort of deal
you can choose your fabric inside and
out you can choose the lapel the lining
the buttons you can write your own
monogram so you look like a Bond villain
endo Chino professionally tailors your
suit and Mail's it to you in a couple of
weeks this week my listeners could get
any premium Indo Chino suit for just 369
bucks at Indo Chino comm when you enter
Shapiro at checkout plus shipping is
free that's endo Chino comm promo code
Shapiro for any premium suit just 369
bucks plus free shipping it's a
fantastic deal for a premium it
made-to-measure suit once you go custom
you're not gonna want to go back go
check them out in Indo Chino comm I've
got an endo chinos it's pretty fabulous
go check them out ok so as I say
Democrats because feelings matter more
than facts because they don't care if
the city of Los Angeles is overrun so
long as they can pat themselves on the
back for their sympathy for the homeless
while the city declines while the tax
base flees while people move out
increasingly to the suburbs to get away
from the center of major cities that are
rotting out in the core at the same time
Democrats are patting themselves on the
back because they spend lots of money
because money that you spend from
somebody not David Koch who spent his
own money on charity if they spend your
money this demonstrates how committed
they are to a cause
case in point today Bernie Sanders has
now promoted a sixteen point three
trillion dollar climate plan on Thursday
the Sanders proposal envisions a
significant expansion of the
government's role in the economy no
Bernie Sanders the socialist no he would
offer billions in subsidies to replace
gas guzzling vehicles with electric ones
by 2030 a new public system of clean
electricity generation that could
sideline private utilities and an
infrastructure program that would remake
much of the economy and employ an
estimated 20 million more Americans this
is one of the beautiful things is one of
the beautiful things about being a
Democrat you can just say stuff like I'm
gonna spend one gajillion dollars and it
will create twenty gajillion jobs and
people are like how anyway just well man
remember when Barack Obama was talking
about shovel-ready jobs that didn't
material
and he was talking about green jobs that
didn't materialize and now Bernie
Sanders is doing the same thing in the
media's like sheer scale of the effort
which the independent from Vermont
compares to FDR's 1940s mobilization to
fight World War two was central to his
message in rolling out the plan right
it's a feature not a bug that it's going
to destroy the American economy and
forced us to spend trillions because
after all we can measure your sympathy
in dollars now your own dollars and the
number of dollars that you wish to take
out of somebody else's pocket it's a
beautiful beautiful thing now this does
result in a great irony which is that
when Bernie Sanders is called on it he's
got nothing so listen to these two clips
is pretty funny he was at a town hall
event yesterday and he's talking about
how we have to transition away from
fossil fuels which if you are worried
about climate change then you do want a
transition away from fossil fuels over
the course of time there is no way to do
it right now the technology is simply
not sophisticated enough there are
certain things that you can do like we
should explore geoengineering building
more infrastructure to prevent against
rising sea levels right building sea
walls there's certain things you can do
for mitigation there are certain things
you can do to heighten adaptation and
making it easier for people to move from
particularly low-lying areas as sea
levels rise for example and then there
are stuff that you can do to actually
mitigate climate change itself some of
that involves shooting sulfur into the
air has been explored this is
geoengineering there's also talked about
technological innovation and it's always
funny to me when people say we have to
subsidize technological innovation okay
well you know who the person who wins
the race to create an alternative energy
source that is even nearly as efficient
as as carbon emissions you know their
reward is all the money's all of them if
you if you are the person who discovers
nuclear fusion right that does not
require the heat of the Sun if you are
the person who discovers that and makes
it cost-effective on a small scale then
you are going to be the wealthiest
person in the history of humanity so
that's a pretty good incentive
nonetheless Bernie Sanders says we have
to prenta shimau now we have to we have
no choice right this very instant it is
no secret that we must transition away
from fossil fuel period and
[Applause]
there ain't no middle ground field right
there's no middle ground okay so
somebody gets up and they say well so
there's no middle ground why are you
driving a car and Bernie's got nothing
you seem out of it about I'm a change of
course it's what ways would you take to
practice what you preach if you were to
become president I know it's stressful
and yet to travel a lot you have to use
fossil fuels no I'm not gonna walk to
California all right you know look you
know I understand that you know we we do
the best we can as an example but I'm
not gonna sit here and tell you that
we're not gonna use fossil fuels oh oh
well well I thought we had no choice
nuts no middle ground I cannot give you
anyone even one specific way in which I
am reducing my carbon footprint but it
doesn't war and we must do something
right is the beautiful thing about being
on the left it's a war against poverty
but I'm not gonna spend my money on it
I'm gonna spend somebody else's money on
it it's a war against climate change but
are you I'm going to continue to apply
of my private jet to Iowa and out of
Iowa and again sympathy can be measured
according to Democrats in how many
dollars from somebody else's pocket you
spend so you get Bernie saying this
people are telling me Bernie the plan
you just released to combat climate
change is expensive and you know what
they're right it is expensive but the
cost of doing nothing is far more
expensive yes this is always the easy
thing to say right the cost of doing
nothing it turns out until you reach
about 2.5 degrees Celsius in global
climate change actually the cost of
doing nothing is less expensive hey
William Nordhaus the Nobel Prize winner
in economics last year as an entire book
I've recommended on the show called
climate casino he does not reject
climate change he does not reject that
the climate is changing and he actually
believes in a carbon tax but even
Nordhaus says yeah there actually is an
economic tipping point at which it is
not worth it to actually invest in
stopping climate change below a certain
point so Bernie Sanders is just full of
it but again it's about people's
intentions in politics these days it's
not about their actual their actual
activity this is how you but but here's
what's hilarious about this the DNC
recognizes that this
an argument very very like that the
worst thing they can do is pitch their
climate change plans in public they're
fine with with pretending that they care
deeply about these crazy climate change
plans put out by aoc and Bernie Sanders
they don't want to talk about it
publicly how do we know this because a
committee within the DNC on Thursday
voted down a proposal for a debate
focused on climate change the DNC
resolution voted against the measure
though a resolution calling for a
climate change debate could still be
considered for a vote by the full
committee on Saturday the committee
defeated the resolution in a 17 to 8
vote so remember that time that every
Democrat said this is the greatest
crisis in the history of humanity and
then they're like let's hold the debate
on it like nah you know cuz then we'll
have to talk about how we want to get
rid of everybody's car and kill their
cows that's it it is it is hilarious
Democrats love talking about problems
and then if somebody proposes an actual
solution to the problem then they get
mad at the solution they say the actual
solution to the problem should be
feelings feelings just change the
language make it so a convicted rapist
is not a convicted felon they're a
justice-involved person make it so that
a homeless person sleeping on the street
you have sympathy for them so much
sympathy you're going to allow them to
loiter in public and pee in the gutter
and do drugs on the open streets and
defecate that's sympathy right there and
if you say you want to clean that up you
want to arrest people who are loitering
do you want their garbage to be thrown
away because it is in fact piles of
garbage if you suggest that there have
to be consequent the people who are who
are mentally ill and living on the
street need to be put in a place where
they can be taken care of if without
their permission if they are seriously
mentally ill because many of these
people cannot actually make intelligent
rational decisions if you are a
schizophrenic
I have schizophrenia my grandfather was
schizophrenic and that it's not somebody
who's capable of making rational
decisions if you say oh you're
unsympathetic sympathy and crappy policy
matter a lot more than sympathy and good
policy so long as you can cast to get
good policy is unsympathetic that
apparently is the way all of this works
okay in just a second I want to get to
the g7 because the United States is in
fact involved in the g7 it's going to be
pretty dicey this time around but first
let's talk about safety so as I say LA
is now overrun with low-level petty
crime they've been a bunch of robberies
in my neighborhood people breaking into
houses one of the
ways that people break into houses is
they ring the doorbell they see if you
are home if you do not answer then they
figure it safe and they try to break
into the house well this is where ring
comes in rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer they're doing just
that protecting millions of people
everywhere this is why they have smart
video doorbells and cameras I've had one
on my house for a very long time all my
friends have them too and you should as
well ring helps you stay connected to
your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivery or a surprise
visitor or god forbid somebody coming to
rob your house they bring the doorbell
you can pick it up anywhere in the world
and they don't know whether you're at
home or not you can also call the police
if it turns out that it's somebody who
is trying to do something criminal go
get an alert you'll be able to see here
and speak to the people who are at your
door
all from your phone makes me feel safer
it makes my wife feel safer obviously we
are deeply concerned about safety around
our house as a subscriber you have a
special offer on a ring welcome kit
available right now at ring comm slash
Ben that's ring comm /ban the kit
includes a video doorbell and a chime
Pro which is just what you need to start
building that ring of security around
your home today go to ring comm slash
Ben that is ring Netcom slash Ben go
check them out alrighty now before we
get to the g7 I have some good news for
you let's say that you're a person who
is looking for a job and you'd like to
work here I'm not gonna tell you what
it's actually like to work here because
that'd be kind of off-putting I mean to
be frank but thankfully our business
isn't deep growing by leaps and bounds
you know I'm old enough to remember when
this business had seven employees we're
now up to almost a hundred employees and
we continue to grow we're growing by
leaps and bounds we are once again
looking to fill another position this
time it is in our social media
department as a content creator so if
you are a meme genius if you are
somebody who's great with social media
and you want to be a content creator
head on over to daily wire comm slash
careers and send your information again
that's daily wear comm slash careers
come be part of our fantastic team we
have a bunch of other positions
available as well I mean we are growing
by leaps and bounds
I used to know the name of everybody who
works here and I'm still learning
everybody's name and I'm one of those
people where I have to actually meet
somebody like four times before I I
realize that their name ought to be
embedded in my memory but you can be one
of those people who requires meeting me
four times for me to recognize you if
you go over to daily wire.com slash
careers also this some coming Tuesday
August 27th 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific it's our latest episode of the
conversation
Michael Knowles will be answering your
questions
I'm on air so make them good my first
question why God why the episode is free
to watch on Facebook and YouTube only
subscribers can ask the questions so
subscribe to daily wire get your
questions answered by Knowles Tuesday
August 27 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific go join the conversation today
also so many announcements
it's that glorious time of the week when
I give a shout-out to a daily where a
subscriber
today it is Darrin Littleton on
Instagram has one heck of a view on his
evening commute look at that in the
picture Darrin's leftist cheers tumblr
is taking a ride on a navy ship as he
empties a few rounds of the awesome
firepower on deck which is just
spectacular the caption reads wishing I
could be a backstage live but I'm busy
sailing the sea of leftist ears hashtag
left his tears tumblr hashtag daily
where hashtag hooyah well sir we wish
you could have been there as well as a
great event but thank you you're doing
something much more important than
listening to us jabber we thank you for
doing what you do and keeping this great
country safe men that members of our
military the members of our Police
Department's thank you guys I mean I get
honestly it's humbling there's a lot of
people who are members of the military
members of the police firefighters
people who are in those positions across
the nation who send me letters talking
about how much they enjoy the show I'm
always like I don't do anything right
like I just jabber you guys are actually
you you have the hardest job you're out
there putting your lives on the line to
defend the country and defend public
order and defend safety with zero thanks
from an entire side of the political
aisle
thank you guys I mean you guys are
spectacular it really is fantastic
enough to talk with some people back
back here about what we can do we need
to have some special programs for
military folks maybe we'll do like a
military tour or something I think
that'd be awesome
all right anyway dad that is that is a
discussion for another day we'll get to
more in just one second go subscribe
over daily wire.com that helps protect
us from the nastiness of the left join
the team and go sign up we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
by the way speaking of democratic
proposals that demonstrates empathy Joe
Biden wants to raise your taxes
dramatically he wants the capital gains
tax to be raised all the way back up to
nearly 40 percent which would basically
double the capital gains tax you want to
sink the stock market this seems like a
pretty damn good way to do it one of the
reasons the stock market has been doing
so well is because if you make capital
gains from your stocks those are taxed
at a far lower rate than normal income
well now Joe Biden wants to get rid of
that differential capital gains get
taxed just like regular income get ready
for the stock market to take a hit well
done Joe Biden but at least you
sympathetic guys at least you
sympathetic okay meanwhile the Trump
administration is prepared to head on
over to the g7 now one of the things I
always find hilarious about these
international conferences is this
pretend nonsense where we're part of a
family of Nations Oh a family of Nations
we're just like a family guys except for
how we hate each other a lot of the time
and disagree and we have our own
particular interests and there is no
actual common interest between some of
the members of the g7 so the g7 it used
to be the g8 he used to include Russia
now it's the g7 plus one it's a group
consisting of Canada France Germany
Italy Japan the UK and the United States
and there are a lot of internal
disagreements about how to how to handle
world affairs in the g7 those are those
disagreements extend on everything from
how to handle global warming and climate
change all the way over to the Iran deal
where the United States has taken a very
hard line and the Europeans wish to
continue to appease the Iranian and the
Iranians and and the evil regime that
takes precedence there according to the
according to the Washington Post Karen
DeYoung and Josh now see writing like an
annual holiday gathering where the main
goal is to get through the day without a
family explosion that's actually kind of
fair one of france's main objectives as
host of this weekend's g7 is to minimize
the chances that President Trump will
blow it up that's the part that's unfair
it's always about Trump blowing it up
it's never about the Europeans taking
crap positions subjects on which to
tread lightly include some of the
biggest problems the world's major
economies are facing including trade the
system of international rules that has
ordered the Democratic world for decades
and climate change according to the US
and other g7 officials now when it comes
to trade the reality is the reason that
trade agreements have been so effective
for the past 30 years 40 years is not
because everybody
agrees that we're all friends it's
specifically because when you lower your
own trade barriers you are helping your
own country so the national interest is
in you lowering your tariffs even if
other people are not lowering their
tariffs this is general rule already
president Trump though has shaken up the
schedule calling at the last minute for
a special meeting to discuss the global
economy senior administration officials
say he will contrast u.s. growth with
Europe's economic doldrums and press his
Pro jobs and fair trade messages well it
is certainly true that the United States
regulatory system our tax system in many
ways is better than Europe's highly
confess Kotori system that generally
penalized is the middle class at
exorbitant rates when it comes to trade
the president is not actually correct in
his general in his general take that
trade is a zero-sum game it is unclear
of course how receptive the others will
be so whatever thoughts Trump might
offer as to how they should shift their
own economic approaches many world
leaders are blaming Trump's trade war
with China and his threats against
Europe and Japan from major contraction
and investment in spending that of
course is inaccurate Germany's economy
has been contracting China's economy was
contracting before the tariffs actually
kicked in Trump's refusal to agree to a
joint view of the climate threat and an
agenda to confront it roiled the first
two g7 meetings he attended in Italy in
27 and in Canada last year well that is
because half of the countries involved
in the g7 make commitments on climate
change and then don't fulfill the
commitments and then virtue signal about
how much they're going to lower
emissions while the United States is
actually lowered emissions more than any
other country since 2014
France hopes to sidestep that issue
there will be no final communique it's
gonna be a it's going to be a bleep show
obviously but that is because frankly
the United States does not have a lot of
the same interests as a lot of the
European countries right now and with
all of that said the question becomes
what President Trump is going to do to
prop up an image of an account of the
economy going into 2020 the Dow is down
about 450 points at this point today
President Trump has ordered US companies
to look for an alternative to China he
tweeted our country has lost stupidly
trillions of dollars with China over
many years they've stolen our
intellectual property at a rate of
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
they want to continue I won't let that
happen
we don't need China and frankly would be
far
better off right he says our great
American companies are hereby ordered to
immediately start looking for an
alternative to China including bringing
your companies home and making your
products in the United States first of
all that is not how law works guys okay
this is like Michael Scott declaring
bankruptcy there he saw Gore's out in
the middle of the office and he goes I
declare bankruptcy
you can't just declare on Twitter that
American companies are immediately
ordered to start looking for an
alternative to China that's how it
tariffs do unless you're placing
sanctions on China like we have
sanctions on Iran that is not what this
is with that said China has unveiled new
tariffs on Chinese goods China will
implement new tariffs on another
seventy-five billion dollars worth of
American goods including autos those
tariffs will range between five and ten
percent earlier in the day stocks were
teetering around flatline after dirham
Paulo the Fed chair delivered a speech
from the in annual central banking
symposium in it he said the Fed would do
what it can to sustain the current
economic expansion he said our challenge
now is to do what monetary policy can do
to sustain the expansion said the
benefits of the strong jobs market
extend to more of those still left
behind as that inflation is centered
firmly around two percent
he also said there's no rulebook for the
us-china trade war he didn't really give
an indication as to whether the rates
will be cut again in September he says
after a decade of progress toward
maximum employment and price stability
the economy is close to both goals which
does not suggest that the Fed is going
to do a lot more in the near future
again I'm not averse to an economic war
with China given that the Chinese are
expanding the world power given the fact
that they use every dollar that they
make in the world economy to pour into a
fistic communist regime that runs
roughshod over the rights of its own
citizens that it tries to expand its
sphere of influence over the South China
Sea
that builds military islands out of a
tolls in the South China Sea I mean that
this is a dangerous geopolitical foe
President Trump I don't mind him saying
that we need to make sacrifices in order
to fight that foe but he needs to give a
national address on that frankly he does
he needs to make Democrats defend why
they would instead enrich the Chinese
government through through mutual trade
but he has to explain why the American
people ought to take a hit on all of
this if he doesn't explain that then
we've got these mixed messages
they're not going to result in anything
good for president Trump as time it
moves to her okay it is a Friday that
means it's time for some mail bag let's
mail bag it up a little bit
Ryan says the Honorable Ben Shapiro when
are you gonna leave that hellhole and
join us here in the great state of Texas
where your taxes get more than a traffic
cone for much less but I digress should
ancestry or DNA databanks be compelled
to or under their own will comply with
law enforcement what is the legal and/or
constitutional ramifications of these
companies complying
well it seems very dicey to compel DNA
data banks or ancestry sites to comply
with federal law enforcement I mean
absent you know compelling search and
seizure usually that has to be directed
against an actual suspect a blanket
dictates that the government should have
access to a DNA database that seems
quite violative of the Fourth Amendment
which bans unreasonable search and
seizure you didn't volunteer your
information to the government you
volunteered it to a company with the
basic understanding that the company was
going to keep that in confidentiality so
I'm really not into the idea of ancestry
companies being forced by the federal
government to turn over vast data banks
now maybe that's a little bit different
if you actually have a reasonable
search-and-seizure namely they have a
crime scene they have a suspect they
want the DNA of that particular suspect
the suspect is on the loose
for example because normally you
actually there have been court cases on
whether you can draw blood and
unreasonable you know in a reasonable
search-and-seizure
in particular cases and Garrett says hey
Ben what interview are our human rights
are they what stated in our founding
documents or is there more to it what's
the counter-arguments of the thinking we
have a human right to immigrate to any
country one libertarians very often want
open borders because they view it as you
human right thanks well human rights are
the rights to life liberty and property
but those rights have to be guaranteed
by the system and to be guaranteed by
the government okay if you are not a
member of that system then you don't
have the right from that government or
you have a right generally but rights
have to be guaranteed the government is
instituted to protect those rights so it
is not that you have anybody in the
world has a right to enter the United
States particularly not if the United
States is giving out welfare goodies
particularly if there are cultural
changes that are inherent in
coming here and then voting right any
country has the right to protect its own
borders because if the country could not
protect its own views of Rights then it
would be very easy to see those rights
overthrown by a change in the government
so the the founding fathers when they
said that there was an inalienable right
they did not mean that those rights were
just out there in the universe and the
government of the United States has the
ability and the capability and the
obligation to protect those for people
around the world that is not how
government works if that were the case
then the United States would have the
moral authority to invade every country
on earth and impose our view of natural
rights which I do not think that we have
Ashley says hey Ben so take a break from
politics can we gather around the
campfire and hear the story of how the
full daily Wired team came together you
know Liz Clavin Alisha and Walsh I'd
love to know how you guys all got the
band together thanks well the first
people to know each other here at the
Daily wire where me and my business
partner Jeremy boring we were introduced
by a guy that I used to work for who's
in the talk radio industry at the time
he wanted to do movies and Jeremy was
the head of the not-so-secret secret
underground Hollywood organization
Friends of Abe which was a bunch of
conservatives in Hollywood so this guy
was my boss at the time he said well Ben
you and Jeremy should talk about that
German I quickly became friends and we
started talking about business ventures
together that was the sort of origin of
our relationship so I've known Jeremy
we've been business partners for almost
a decade and then the next person in the
group that I met was Alicia Krause so
Alicia and I were co-hosts so I knew a
little bit when she was a producer for
Sean Hannity and then she became a
co-host on a morning show that I did
here in Los Angeles called the morning
answers me and Alicia Krauss and Brian
Whitman and we became close friends from
that then Jeremy and I founded a company
called truth revolt Andy we shall worked
for us over there and with us over there
and we also brought on Andrew Clavin at
that time to do videos with us so Clavin
moved over and was doing some work at PJ
TV still and he was doing work for us
over at Ruth revolt so that's how I got
to know Andrew Noel's joined when we
started daily wire he was there
basically from inception but he started
off doing kind of social media for us
and he was doing some some behind the
scenes office work and it turns out he
was real crappy at that so we gave him a
show and then finally
at walsh joined because we really enjoy
man man hilarious and we hired him so
that that's how all the members of the
band got together in terms of the
OUTFRONT talent out the fact is that the
company's a lot more than the OUTFRONT
talent we're friends with a lot of the
people we work with thank god it's a
really fun company to work for as much
as I kid about it and the team that is
behind the scenes is I think much more
or just as important as the team that is
out in front of the cameras and they
have a much harder job cuz they don't
get the credit for it but they do an
unbelievable job each and every day as
much as I make fun of them Tate says
dear mr. Shapiro every week it seems you
are recommending a new book to read thus
I was curious as to how many books you
read a year what's the fastest you've
read through a book well it depends on
the length of the book obviously now
some books take a while so I'm reading
this biography of Grant by Ron chernow I
got thousand pages that's probably gonna
take me a couple of weeks in my free tin
my free time but the fact is that if I
have time during the week usually
Shabbat is when I get my reading done
Sabbath is when I get my reading done
I'll usually read at least two books
over the course of a Sabbath and then I
usually read maybe one the rest of the
week so two to three books I'm averaging
I think over the course of a week so but
that really depends I mean when I'm in
the middle of writing a book then I'm
reading a lot for background and so I
may end up reading five or six books in
a week so I would say over the course of
a year I probably average somewhere in
the neighborhood of 120 to 150 books
somewhere somewhere in there now that
does not mean that and that's excluding
some of the books that I just skim right
there are some books where you can read
the intro in the conclusion and skim
everything in the middle and you get the
main argument of the book but I would
say I'd read probably 100 books cover to
cover and then I'd probably skim another
100 to 150 a year so something like that
probably Thomas says good day saw when
arguing Christianity with atheists they
tend to go straight to slavery in the
Bible
can you explain biblical slavery how it
differs or compares to slavery in
America also I loved your conversation
with Ravi Zacharias are you gonna bring
on Ray Comfort or Frank Couric in the
future thanks for all you I'd be happy
to have on anybody I mean we have on a
wide variety of guests as far as
biblical slavery so the Bible does not
mandate that people keep slave
hey this is first of all second of all
the Bible has historically been used as
a freedom document Christians were some
of the first people to outlaw slavery
among fellow Christians and
co-religionist were not allowed to be
enslaved by Christianity early on in the
development of the Christian Church now
over time that was extended obviously
to people who are not Christian and
that's one of the great stories of
humanity is the development from
enslaving of even your co-religionists
to slavery being eliminated among
intergroup rivals and because the vast
majority of human history people have
held slaves slavery in the Bible is
designed to restrict what slavery was
slavery in the Bible is a series of
restrictions on how you can treat your
slaves so according to Tom utak law you
have to feed your slave before you feed
yourself according to Tom utak law
according to biblical law if somebody is
an indentured servant for you you have
to give them their freedom at the at the
end of 7 years maybe beforehand
depending on if it's the Jubilee year
and if somebody wants to stay because
they already have a family with you then
you actually are supposed to hammer a
and all through their earlobe to
represent the fact that they are doing
something wrong because the idea is that
they should be a free person subject
only to God not to another human being
the treatment of slaves in in the Bible
is supposed to be a lot lot lot more
humane than American slavery and people
were not supposed to be treated as
property they were supposed to be
treated as fellow human beings who owed
you a debt basically now does that mean
that it is right no but the Bible and
this is one of the problems with folks
talking about the Bible who don't know
what they're talking about the Bible
does two things one it establishes
eternal values but two it is also
dealing with a specific set of people at
a specific time it is talking to a
specific group of people at a specific
time and their attempts to curb human
nature in the Bible so at the time of
the Bible everyone held slaves so is the
Bible attempting to make slavery broader
or is it attempting from narrow slavery
is it attempting to make slavery more
humane or is it attempting to make it
less humane right the Bible is obviously
attempting to make it significantly more
humane significantly narrower and the
Bible is is telling a group of people
who held slaves and we're not going to
give them up that you need to move
toward eventually abolition of slavery
which is how every abolitionist pretty
much ever has read the Bible from
William Wilberforce to Frederick
Douglass this is how abolitionists have
read the Bible and I think that is
eminently correct so you have to
understand that when you are trying to
read the Bible just as a text but the
Bible is trying to accomplish two
purposes to express universal human
values about human relationships and
good and evil and also that the Bible is
trying to speak to a particular people
at a particular time and wean them away
from bad ideas this is what Maimonides
says about sacrifice for example
that pagan peoples used to perform
sacrifices and the sacrifices were
designed to propitiate the gods they
were designed to feed the provides
something to God that God couldn't get
from you and Maimonides suggests that
what biblical sacrifice was supposed to
do is take that out of the realm of the
pagan and instead make it symbolic that
you understand that really you owe your
life to God and that you have sinned and
really it should be you who's paying the
price but instead you need to feel that
viscerally and so you're forced to bring
a sacrifice and there's a lot of weaning
in the Bible away from more primitive
views and toward more developed
civilizational views okay well you know
we don't have time for things I like or
things I hate because we just went a
little bit more long today but we will
be back here a little bit later today
with two additional hours or we'll see
you here on Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everyone its Andrew Klavan host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know the
saying go woke go broke man I hope
that's true but America's top CEOs are
now saying that businesses have to stop
thinking about business so much and do
some of that virtue stuff they've heard
so much about let's talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show
[Music]